Bringing back dinosaurs would probably end
in an… unfortunate outcome, as the Jurassic
Park franchise has shown us countless times.
So, I think most of us would agree that while
resurrecting dinosaurs through some miraculous
future technology would be cool, it’s almost
certainly not a good idea.
But I can’t deny, I’ve still always been
interested in the concept of a responsibly-run
prehistoric reserve where nothing goes wrong
and the dinosaurs don’t eat you.
That’s the basic concept behind the fictional
park of Prehistorica, a biological nature
preserve where resurrected dinosaurs and other
prehistoric animals are treated with care
and the fences actually work.
Prehistorica is a worldbuilding project created
by Joshua Dunlop, a talented artist and creator
who you can follow and support in the links
below.
And since we sadly can’t truly visit Prehistorica,
for this entry into the archive, I’ll be
taking on the role of tour guide and giving
you a glimpse of the well-managed prehistoric
reserve that I think we’ve all secretly
wanted to vacation at…
The fictional reserve is set in the future,
on an enormous artificial island.
Aptly named ‘Pangea,’ the island supports
over twenty different biomes including tropical
and subtropical rainforests, deserts, mountains,
tundra, woodlands, grasslands, mangroves,
and more — all of which are home to a variety
of prehistoric life.
Our tour will take us across the entire island,
and we’ll learn quite a bit about the species
here along the way!
So, get ready to discover the wonders of a
world lost to time…
Welcome to Torosaurus Trail, the first stop
on our tour.
Here, you can drive through the vast open
plains in an autonomous vehicle, and get a
close look at the one-and-only Torosaurus
herd.
These large frilled herbivores have grown
accustomed to the armored viewing vehicles,
and will often lumber close by them — allowing
for some exciting close encounters.
And next to these vehicles, it’s easier
to appreciate just how large even the newborns
can get.
While you observe these magnificent creatures,
a park ranger might point out the difference
between triceratops and torosaurus.
Some scientists have actually theorized the
larger torosaurus is actually just the adult
form of triceratops — although more recent
studies indicate they’re a distinctive genus.
If unique, Torosaurus had one of the largest
skulls of any known land animal!
Fascinating stuff.
Away from the plains, in the misty jungles
of Majungasaurus Mountain, you’ll have the
opportunity to see some truly mighty theropods.
From an underground viewing station, you can
get up close and personal with the only majungasaurus
pack on Prehistorica.
Right now, it’s feeding time, and dinner
is delivered in from above by custom drones
that lower the specialized lab-grown meat
safely into the majungasaurus habitat — a
vast region, which, like most environments,
is sectioned off with advanced futuristic
barriers to ensure the dinosaurs don’t eat
each other… or parks guests.
While you watch the majungasaurus pack chow
down on their air-delivered meal, you might
be interested to learn their teeth are serrated,
and they have more teeth than most genuses
in their family.
These fearsome fangs likely helped majungasaurus
take down small sauropods like Rapetosaurus
— a theory supported by Majungasaurus toothmarks
on Rapetosaurus bones.
Down the mountain, you can take a stroll through
the calming, temperate Wildwood, where you
might spot some gentle giants.
This unique genus of stegosaurid herbivores
is incredibly well mannered, but can be a
little clumsy with the large point spikes
on their bodies which help them defend from
predators.
So, it’s best to view the Kentrosaurus from
a safe distance on one of the many elevated
viewing platforms.
If you’re wondering about the spikes, we
can theorize from real fossils that Kentrosaurus
had long, pointed spikes in the back transitioning
into shorter and flatter plates near the front
— with 15 pairs in total!
In short: Kentrosaurus was likely a very well-defended
dinosaur.
If you’re not afraid of a little adventure,
you can jump on a guide boat and make your
way down the muddy Diabloceratops River.
Here, you might be able to spot a Diabloceratops
wading through the slow-moving waters to cool
off in the hot afternoon sun.
To ensure these animals aren’t pulled out
of their natural rhythms, the tour boats don’t
get too close.
It’s worth noting the concept of Diabloceratops
wading in rivers like a hippopotamus is purely
speculative.
Many of the most unique behaviors of modern
animals wouldn’t be preserved in the fossil
record, so we can assume the same would be
true for dinosaurs.
And since Diabloceratops likely lived in a
region full of lakes and floodplains during
the Cretaceous, it’s a logical guess that
a good wallowing would keep the horned-faced
herbivores comfortable.
Further downriver, the tour boats drift around
the bend of Suchomimus Stream, a region where
you might see some of Prehistorica’s river-dwelling
carnivores.
Believe it or not, the animal you see here
is just a juvenile, and the adults get considerably
larger.
But don’t worry, the artist states these
water giants can’t get close to the boat
thanks to an invisible fence system and non-intrusive
underwater barriers that keep their toothy
jaws far away from park visitors.
Some paleontologists believe Suchomimus is
a variant of the better known Baryonyx.
If unique, Suchomimus was likely larger than
its cousin, with some estimates reaching 34
feet, or 10.3 meters.
And the author notes specimens of Baryonyx
can also be found on Prehistorica, just in
a separate region, as both species are quite
territorial.
Venturing all the way out to the tropical
coast, there’s an opportunity to get a bird’s-eye-view
of the island of Pangea.
If you take a ride in a Coastal Skybox, you’ll
get not only a view of the stunning cerulean
waters — but might also catch a glimpse
of some of Prehistorica’s flying pterosaur
species.
The artist imagines the various pterosaurs
of Prehistorica aren’t contained in an aviary,
but are allowed to nest freely on the coast
thanks to each one being fitted with a tracker.
Real world pterosaur fossils have been found
in an incredible number of locations all over
the globe, as this order was extremely diverse
and successful.
When first discovered, people in the 18th
and 19th century were baffled by these remains
— and some theorized pterosaurs were actually
a lost order of flying marsupials.
Today, we of course know better — although
it’s important to note that despite a common
misconception, pterosaurs are an order separate
from dinosaurs.
On a state-of-the-art ferry, you can tour
Archelon Harbour.
Or, if you’re feeling adventurous, you can
grab yourself a kayak and get even closer
to some incredible prehistoric life.
If you paddle near the shallow waters of the
coastal islands, you can watch Archelon Turtles
glide beneath your boat.
These enormous marine reptiles might be a
little intimidating due to their sheer size,
but Archelon Turtles are actually some of
the most docile and friendly creatures in
Prehistorica.
And I have to say, looking at this scene in
particular… it’s hard not to wish that
this was a real place.
Real Archelons weren’t quite as big as Prehistorica’s
resurrections, which the author notes aren’t
always 100% accurate, but they got pretty
close — with some fossils measuring 15 feet,
or 4.5 meters in length.
Sea turtles were once thought to be Archelon’s
closest living relatives, but now scientists
theorize Archelon might actually be a completely
separate lineage...
Heading back inland, you can make your way
down to Plesiosaurus Pond.
Through underground viewing zones, you and
your family can take in the many species from
the Plesiosaurs order that call Prehistorica
their home.
From behind the safety of the glass, you can
watch Plesiosaurs glide through the water
and, according to the artist, might even get
a chance to feed them, with a park ranger’s
assistance of course.
One neat fact to know about the Plesiosaurs
before you toss some food their way is that
Plesiosaur fossils were discovered as far
back as the 19th century.
One of the most important early specimens
was found by Mary Anning, a pioneering English
paleontologist who made vital contributions
to the field — though sadly never got the
credit she deserved in her lifetime.
Recently, however, the plesiosaur genus Anningasaura
was named in her honor!
The sun is now getting low, but we still have
time for a few more stops here at Prehistorica.
In the fictional Brachylophosaurus Badlands,
if you come at the right time, you could be
some of the lucky few who get to see the first
interaction between a Brachylophosaurus hatchling
and the rest of their herd.
These beaked dinosaurs are elegant and peaceful,
making these first meetings a beautiful experience
for the guests who get to see one.
Millions of years after going extinct, these
remarkable creatures are resuming these ancient
cycles.
Some real Brachylophosaurus specimens are
notable for being exceptionally well-preserved
— with some remains of these mid-sized hadrosaurids
possessing skin impressions and even the remains
of what they ate recently.
It seems their diet included leaves, conifers,
ferns, and flowering plants… and we can
assume Prehistorica caretakers are feeding
them their favorites.
And finally, as the sun sets on the island
of Pangea, we’ll make our last stop on this
tour millions of years in the making.
The Brachiosaur Redwoods are home to a wide
range of species, the largest of which is
the titular Brachiosaurus herd.
These titanic sauropods occupy a large area,
and migrate each day to a lake where they
enjoy a swim before moving to the redwoods
to graze.
The artist imagines you can view this vast
herd from treetop walkways, which would be
an incredible sight.
While you watch the brachiosaurus munch on
vegetation, you might be interested to learn
these world-famous sauropods have been estimated
at over 66 feet or 20 meters in length — and
might have weighed more than 12 African elephants.
A seriously impressive genus to end our tour!
Though the sun has set on Prehistorica, you
can check out the work of talented creator
Joshua Dunlop by using the links in the description
below.
Also, thanks for watching.
If you enjoyed this entry, you can help make
these videos possible by liking, subscribing,
and hitting the notification icon to stay
up to date on all things Curious.
See you in the next video.